[Music]
and what is going on
good morning dr john how are you how are
you today i'm great
how are you i'm doing all right
fantastic i have this weird
uh i don't know it's like allergies of
some sort
i feel like i'm talking an octave lower
but anytime anybody says allergies
everyone goes sure covet right so
whatever i've got something
going on but it's cool and you you're
doing well
i'm doing all right yeah fantastic just
got over a cold it was not covered it
was a sure
sure it was ann c19 we all know what you
have
all right so hey what's going on how can
i help well
so i have a 21 year old son
you sound like you're dealing with you
sound 25
well i'm not well well done well done
you're keeping that
you're keeping your voice young and well
done well hopefully i keep the rest of
me young too then
i can't even comment on that it's the
21st century but i will tell you
good job good work on the voice so far i
sound like a 90 year old
so you have 21 year old and then what he
is struggling with anxiety and
depression
and i feel like everything we do to try
to help him is wrong
how do we know if we are actually
helping him or are we enabling him
oh if you're helping him he gets more
anxious and more depressed right
so what what does that mean what does
that look like
you know it's gosh it's been a long few
years here
with this it's been a roller coaster
ride that we just can't seem to get off
it never ends
and he has obviously good days he has
bad days and the bad days are bad
you know there's anger there's holes in
my walls there's broken things around my
house on those angry days
yeah and then it turns into i don't want
to come home
because i don't know who i'm going to
get am i going to get
the you know happy-go-lucky kid that i
remember from
his childhood or am i going to get this
angry swollen
monster nobody wants to be around
so when did this start
probably it started when he was in high
school
it's progressively gotten worse and
we've tried therapy we we did therapy
when he was a minor and he had no choice
to go because we made him go
which isn't necessarily the greatest
thing either because
you know you don't want to be there
you're not going to do the work
um once he was old enough he quit going
when we couldn't make him go anymore
he has recently started seeing somebody
again but i don't think it's very often
i think it's maybe you know once
once a month once every few weeks kind
of a thing
okay and i feel like he needs to be
there weekly right now
okay so
he's living in our home by the way and i
think i think i made that clear
about that is he in school or anything
he is not
he is actually currently doing nothing
and that is
just maddening to my husband and i we
just we
we can't wrap our heads around that some
days he doesn't get out of bed
yeah and then it's and then you're like
okay well that this is a depression
thing and we can't just
make him go away because we know that
you know that
he can't sit in an apartment and do that
and days on end nobody knows
so he can and that's where this is going
to get hard so i'm going to be i'm going
to be honest with you as we walk through
this okay
okay and when you hang up you can say i
don't like that guy and
lucky for you you didn't this is all
free right so
this may be worth the price you pay for
it
um before
i'm gonna be super honest as transparent
as i can be
and i need you to promise me as a mom
that you will be able to hear this
within
with a vision for moving forward not
trying to replay the past is that cool
absolutely need to move forward these
are hard things to hear okay
the last thing i want to ask was get a
little bit more information did anything
set this off does he come from was home
chaotic does do either you or your
husband struggle with depression or
anxiety was there
were y'all ever medicated growing up is
there divorce was he abused
what anything that set any of this off
nope his dad and i have been married for
25 years
been together forever and there's you
know we've
in my opinion had a good home life you
know they had a
you know they the kids have had a good
upbringing and it's not
been you know there wasn't chaos there
wasn't fighting we don't
you know my husband and i don't have
knock down drag out brawl type things
you know
obviously we argue because we're a
married couple and that happens wait
what just kidding
yeah right nobody nobody argues in
marriage
never never especially in my house so do
you there's never yelling there's never
anything like that did he experience
bullying or abuse at school
did he have a bad breakup did somebody
treat him awful
yes he had a bad breakup okay um but it
was years ago
um he's had bad breakups since then
okay you know he's had a long-term
girlfriend that's been off and on
and that hasn't helped matters sure um
she you know they they just they they
they butt heads and it's just not been
good for either of them
okay but that's up to them they got to
fix that and i know that and i don't get
involved in that i just
stay away and say that's not my business
and you guys
need to work it out okay um so here's um
here's here's what next steps look like
he's 21. he's a grown man
who has absolutely no business punching
holes in the walls of your house
he doesn't get to do that he doesn't
give to live
rent free under a blanket in his room
and do nothing
he's got to experience the reality of
the world
to say it like my friend henry cloud
says it he's got to get some problems
and he doesn't have any and
here's where that gets really hard if
he's had
years of depression he's probably
threatened suicide or talked about
vaguely i want to hurt myself or i'm
having dark thoughts or things like that
and those often i don't mess around with
that i call
in the calvary when people that i love
threaten suicide and
i've worked with thousands of college
kids and high school kids over the years
and when they want to be seen and heard
they can say the phrase i'm having dark
thoughts and the entire institution
shuts down
from the president down that's how they
they they had they earn control that way
and i take it real real serious you will
never hear me say the words
they're just faking it never right
um but they can control everything
and so at some point he needs to know he
can no longer control you
he can no longer run your home and he's
running your home
he's running your marriage he's running
everything
and you can't give him that anymore he's
a 21 year old man
and if he walks out the door and hurts
himself
this is going to be hard to hear that
would be a choice he made
especially if you tell him i'm this your
rent here runs out your top lease here
runs out
and we love you and we will always be
here we're going to have sunday dinner
on the table every sunday and we want
you here if you ever want to go get
coffee we're here to talk
but at this point he's a 21 year old man
so if you put things like if you want
to still be on our car insurance or
still want us to pay for your phone
but you have to fill in the blank then
you're using power and threats and it
doesn't work
it just doesn't you become a politician
at that point
right now you transition up to we love
you and support you
and here's our boundaries you don't
punch holes in our walls
you don't you don't lay in your bed all
day at our house
if you're having a depressive episode we
understand that those are real
we expect you to go do the work to go
meet with a professional who's going to
walk you through that
you get a job so you can afford the
health insurance so you can get
a low dose medication while you work
whatever you need to do right
um but he's 21 and he's got to start
making some hard decisions on his own
and that starts with him realizing
there's not going to be people wiping
his butt anymore
and there's not going to be people
making his bed anymore and not people at
his beck and call who are scared to
death to move the wrong way because he
controls y'all
oh man eggshells yeah we got a lot of
them around our house
and here's what happens with eggshells
in your home do you have younger kids in
the home
i have another son yes how old is he
he's
16. okay
and he's absorbing every second of this
i know
that's part of our that's really part of
our problem is we
we know he's seeing this we've talked to
him about it you know and
we've told him you know this is this is
going to end
we've my husband and i have talked about
you know
making a plan to get him out and my
older son not my younger sister
he has to live here until he's done with
high school
about getting him out and you know
frankly
i mean we've talked to the point where
we said let's let's
you know put up the money to put a
deposit down in a rent the first month
rent on an apartment and tell him the
rest is on him
he's moved out before he hasn't lived
here every day since high school
sure he has moved out before and he did
live on his own
and that's where one of the nasty
breakups came and he came back
well he never left and it's been a while
and
it's time for him to go we know this we
know this
is just oh my gosh so here's a here's a
cool
here's a cool way to do this go out with
your husband
and y'all get off campus off-site i call
houses campbell like get
get out of the house and y'all go spend
a half day together
and i want y'all to mourn the kid that
you love with all your heart
because you're still trying to hold on
to that 12 year old little boy
all right let me tell you this yeah i'm
gonna i'm gonna tell you a story that's
not fair
okay i was i've been out of town for a
few
for several days i got back home and
while i was gone i missed my son's fifth
grade to sixth grade
like the fifth grade there's a
graduation for everything now when i was
a kid we had one
and now there's a million of them right
there's a fifth grade ceremony of some
sort
and he won a couple of nerd awards
because his parents are dorks and he won
some academic awards because he
and he works really hard and i pulled up
my
my truck and he ran outside he just got
done with the sh
with his shower he ran outside with this
big poofy hairdo
in his underwear met me in my truck so
i've been gone for several days holding
these certificates
and i pulled him up he's about eight
feet tall now even though he's 11
and i pulled him up into the truck i
didn't even have time to get out
and he told me the story of the awards
and the certificates and
the nice thing that a teacher said was
one of the
awesomest moments of my parenting life
and you've had those and now you looked
up and it's 10 years after that
and you remember those and that same
little boy is now a grown man punching
holes in your wall
and what you've got to do is you've got
to put down that 11 year old little boy
that you're still trying to hang on to
and deal with the 21 year old man that's
terrorizing your home
yep and i know that's hard so i want you
and your husband to go out i want you to
mourn that
talk about it laugh about it and spend
some time saying
remember when remember when and then
move that toggle to
and here's where now is and be really
clear
on the same page is it going to be 30
days is it going to be 45 days are we
going to give him 500
are we going to give him no dollars um i
if
i like sounding all tough and hard like
yeah you tell him
i would do what you're doing i would put
down a deposit
and say we found you an apartment we put
down a deposit for you we're not giving
you cash we're going to give them
a deposit so that we l we love you
and i'll even go do a mom thing and i'll
put some cereal in your
in your i don't you know what i mean
i'll fill your bridge because i'm your
mom and you got to eat
maybe maybe i'll give you a dozen eggs
yes and then hey this is it
you're a grown man and then on sundays
you come to our house and we're gonna
have lunch
and we will always answer the phone when
you call but you're not moving back in
and we'll we will call our friend so and
so if you say you need a job we'll help
but here's our boundaries i want you and
your husband to work out those
boundaries together
and then look each other in the eye and
commit this is it
because you got a 16 year old in that
house that deserves your full attention
and you know what else deserves your
full attention you need your marriage
back
yes we do you lose your intimacy nobody
wants to
nobody wants to have sex when there's a
hole in the wall right nobody wants to
go on dates when you're worried about
what a 21 year old
person in your house who's who's
struggling is going to do to the house
right everything gets messed up and you
all deserve your marriage back
right yes so
yeah we're all the one thing that we
have stayed
pretty constant about this is that we
are
we still connect with each other
good job man good job different it's
different when there's a 21 year old in
here that you're
that you're you're scared that there's
going to be chaos that's right you're
scared of right
so here's the thing i'm proud of you i
know this is hard
but it ends today it ends today
um you got i would give you 30 days from
today
and the moment y'all make this you're
going to be nervous and you're going to
be
and you're also going to start feeling
relief your 16 year old son is going to
feel relief i want y'all to take him out
talk about what y'all did right about
this talk about hey we let this go on
too long and we're sorry
you're our son and double down on that
one and if your
older son calls and threatens to hurt
himself call 9-1-1
call 9-1-1 send in the cavalry send in
the professionals to deal with a grown
man making threats
okay and be there for him
but you gotta let him go thank you so
much for the call and
hey and uh how about this i'm gonna send
you a copy i'll send you two we're gonna
stay on the line we're gonna send you
two copies of
my book redefining anxiety i'm gonna
send it to you for free
give one to him it's easy to read and he
may throw it at you or whatever
that's fine it's not gonna hurt my
feelings and i want you as a family to
read the other one
that way you have a picture of some ways
you can navigate this you cannot fix
your son
you can just love him and you can love
him by starting by holding boundaries